I've hello everybody welcome to Sunday
morning science with John Perry and my
guest today Shannon Q Shannon is going
to help us dig through the the science
of staying sane during the virus
lockdown so Shannon I guess we should
probably start for anyone who doesn't
know you
I mean I assume some of the people here
are from your channel but for the people
who do not know you who are you what is
your background why are you going to be
talking us about mental health during a
lockdown and then what what do you do on
the internet because you're quite active
there so I am quite active on the
interwebs yes that's true I am Shannon Q
I have a YouTube channel called Sheena q
and on that channel I talk about the
intersection of psychology and faith and
my primary focus is actually engaging in
complex dialogues I try to approach
issues that are generally controversial
and encourage of better discourse
surrounding those issues so I have a lot
of dialogues on my channel and on top of
that I do some edited videos about the
intersection of psychology and faith and
mental health advocacy I have a
background in psychology I have an
honours degree in psychology from st.
Mary's University in Halifax Nova Scotia
those for anybody who doesn't know where
that is that's the little tiny province
on the on the far east coast of Canada
just above me and yeah how far are you
from Montreal like oh it would be like a
15 hour drive dank drive I think to get
to Montreal yeah and that's why Shannon
and I have never met in person though we
have done many projects together online
one of my primary focus is mental health
advocacy I am NOT a clinician I'd like
for that to be very clear distinction I
don't I'm not a therapeutic psychologist
my background was in perceptual
cognition and communication theory but I
am very staunch support
of science communication around the
topics of mental health and mental
health advocacy and I think right now
that's more important than ever so I
appreciate the opportunity to come here
and and help share some of my background
and an expertise in communicating these
general topics to people yeah how long
when did we meet how did we you and I
first meet was it on all non sequitur
show I was before that actually I met
you because you did on your state of
casually channel the video about going
to the Ark Encounter and it was at the
same time and you had mentioned that you
were talking to Nathaniel J gene Olson
okay and I was reading replacing Darwin
that's right I was like I have to ask
him questions because I'm reading that
book and he's actually madness so that's
how we met if I remember correctly yeah
and then we went on the non sequitur
show after that when Nathaniel came on
to debate Herman Mays right yeah that's
right so yeah I guess our first public
appearance was on the non sequitur show
together so which sadly disappeared the
non sequitur show is is no more but so I
Shannon has been doing really good work
trying to calm people down and in these
debates surrounding controversial topics
so a lot of stuff around religion and
atheism she's been kind of like the I
guess like a coach to help people
calm down and have rational
conversations with each other and you
know she puts out dumpster fires as what
Shannon does unless you knock on
psychology or like gay rights or
something and then Shannon Shannon will
rip your head off
so so yeah I want to have you on here
for a while and this is like the perfect
opportunity there's so much weird stuff
we've never been in a situation like
this before nothing like this I mean
this is this is beautiful in one way and
that the entire world does do
with this same problem at the same time
we're all doing it a little bit
different ways but so it's kind of
beautiful in that way and it's obviously
horrifying for the fact that people are
dying from this disease and there's a
lot of people want to blame people want
to blame Chinese culture people want to
blame conspiracy theory there's all
sorts of things going around IP towers
that's anyone I've seen and it blows my
mind yeah there's and there's yeah just
insane amounts of misinformation and of
course just this this weirdness of we're
all stuck in our houses here in North
America's is the way that we've done it
and this seems to be what pretty much
everyone is doing everywhere I just read
this morning that Panama is doing a
thing where their culture is so outside
all the time that the lockdown has not
been working so they just went to like
every other day men can be outside and
women can be outside just so they can
more easily police it and get like get
people on trouble so there's it's really
interesting to see how different
cultures are trying to deal with this
because of the different ways that
they're structured and you know China
was able to because of that they just
have so much top-down power they just
force everyone to stay inside here are
you guys actually legally on lockdown
or is it advised lockdown there's so
there's a state of emergency here and I
am in Nova Scotia where we are not
legally allowed right now to have to
congregate in numbers of more than five
and if you are and you can only do that
if it's necessary like if there's
there's something that deems that
congregation of people to be necessary
if we all of our parks are closed
there's social distancing rules
completely in effect you need to
maintain two meters of distance from
everybody at all times but you know our
stores are still open so like the the
supply chain still still running but
most of the businesses are shut down
and most of the people that are able to
like me are working from home so there's
spot like all of our parks are closed
public spaces are for the most part
closed but this has been rolling out
slowly and I think there are some
reasons for that that people maybe don't
grasp as well which is an interesting
thing to discuss that you know so like
psychologically when you're looking at
crowd control you can't just say guess
what today everybody's locked inside
there's a lot like you need to think
about the supply chain you need to think
about other people's access to
necessities you need to think about how
people are going to initially respond
whether there's gonna be like some sort
of backlash or if you should roll it out
you need to put logistics in place but
yeah right now we're we're predominantly
on lockdown yeah it's it's same thing in
Montreal and uh yeah so yeah we're stuck
at home but I mean people are going out
for walks and jogs and you know taking
their dogs out so there there actually
is a lot of people going outside when
the weather is nice but it's just you
can't get near anybody and you can't be
in more than couples of two or I think I
think if you have kids you're allowed to
be with your kids obviously with the
people that you're in lockdown with but
it's uh yeah it's it's very very strange
so how how are you and yours doing
coping with this I'm okay I'm an
inherently social person so it's a
climate I think to being you know
completely inside it's been difficult
for me yeah I also have multiple
sclerosis so I've been four and my son
has asthma so I mean we have been inside
for a month with no interaction with
other people pretty much at all right
I've only left the house three times and
that was to go down the street to the
grocery store to get my grocery order
dropped in my trunk so that aspect is
difficult for me because I had you know
a very regiment
busy active social life and personal
life and I was involved in a lot of you
know sports and I you know travel to the
office every day I run a baseball league
I coached my kids soccer team I played
soccer I you know had lots of social
events to go to I have a nine year old
he has a lot of social events they
usually ask to go I did do with his
birthday party being canceled because of
essent
and you know the psychological aftermath
of that with a nine year old while
trying to grapple with you know
everything in his life shaking shake and
now I'm also going to now my new
struggle which I'm working my way
through is while working full time from
home and you know the lockdown the
existential anxiety of you know what's
gonna happen the uncertainty is now I'm
also going to be his full-time teacher
because school is moving yeah in home
there's a lot to deal with but a general
but the important thing is that I'm
doing fine ya know but and some of the
things that we're gonna talk about are
the reasons that I'm doing fine as
opposed to you know crazy which is a
natural state to begin actually in this
situation but there's things you can do
so what are the main problem like mental
health problems that people are
suffering from right now like any this
is obviously we we've seen a huge drop
in crime which is awesome
but also a surge in domestic violence
which makes sense people are stuck at
home and they're getting on each other's
nerves and but what do you yeah what are
you seeing is the is the biggest the
most common issues that people are
having it's difficult to say with any
sort of certainty what the most common
issue is because I spoke to you a little
bit about this yesterday as I was
researching that you know you might come
as a surprise but there isn't a huge
body of research regarding how people
how groups of people react to this
situation because it's an unprecedented
situation so there just isn't a body of
data there will be no pressing analyze
will be but at present there isn't so
really all I can go by is gleaning from
what I see in people
and you know what I see on social media
but I see as I'm you know watching other
forms of media and interacting with
people and I interact with a large group
of people because I have multiple
relatively large size platforms and I've
been kind of looking into this and
reading other sort of like blogs in
Psychology Today blogs about this and
there's a couple things that are of
primary concern to me and there are
things that are generally consistent so
I can start with the things that are
generally consistent the things that
would be generally consistent are it's
just situational anxiety just acute
situational anxiety and depression as a
result of uncertainty regarding you know
your health your income the the
situation with your children being
concerned about family members that
you're segregated from that may or may
not be ill like there's there's myriad
reasons to have situational anxiety
right now inability to control
circumstances inability to affect change
on positive change that you previously
would have been able to in the lives of
others in your in your life or support
them in the fashion that you would like
to or feeling as though you don't have
the support system that you previously
had access to all of those things can
cause situational anxiety and depression
that acute onset and if you don't have a
history of depression or anxiety you may
not have even thought about looking into
some of the coping strategies and
resources available to you during during
this sort of mental health I mean I
would call this it's good I fear that
this there will be like a mental health
crisis if we don't act quickly like
we're very very focused on our physical
health you know not actually getting the
virus but the mental health
repercussions of a situation like this
are going to be they're gonna ripple
forth through time like yeah so so the
more we can do now to kind of focus on
it the better chance people will have
coming out the other end okay and maybe
with a better understanding of how
important taking care of your mental
health is yeah so I think that's what
that's the
dominant thing that I think generally
everybody's going to touch on to a
certain degree like no matter who you
are where you are that affected your
mental health I think would have to
almost be being affected right now you
think so my question around that is so
is is the way that we deal with the
situational depression and situational
anxiety is it the same as the way you
deal with chronic anxiety and chronic
depression or their differences there
and how it's how a psychologist would
treat that it depends on theirs well
there's three different fields of mental
health that you could look at and each
of them is going to approach it from a
different perspective so if there's a
counseling field this IQ psychiatric
field and the psychological field know
most psychologists actually aren't in
the business of therapy most
psychologists are actually studying
specific aspects of human behavior and
length or you know a general component
of how outcomes work and therapies
practices how crowds behave like there's
multiple fields in psychology um
psychiatrists are probably going to
treat the more chronic cases like people
who have a you know a genetic propensity
or a long-term situational trauma
for example that's caused an actual
physiological change in the Kannada chol
structure that you know needs focus
treatment and that's treated with drugs
a lot well I wouldn't say why sometimes
yeah I just say a lot is because drugs
aren't always the answer you there's no
there's literally no magic pill that
will cure a mental health disorder at
all a psychiatric disorder you can't
just go to the doctor and get a
prescription written and then that
solves your problem antipsychotics are
something that would always be needed
for example but if antidepressants or
anti yangtze olynyk's
aren't something that should always be
needed they should be used as a transit
transitional period while you're going
through the therapeutic work of you know
getting yourself better analyzing you
know where what your triggers are and
learning how to manage them so that you
can mitigate the effects of your mental
health disorder so they
can be used and are an absolute
requirement in many cases but just say
they're used a lot it's entirely
dependent on this situation so dependent
depends on your perspective - I guess
like somebody like me I actually
personally think that they're used a lot
more than they need to be yeah but that
that doesn't negate the fact that they
are an absolute requirement in a lot of
circumstances and a counselor wouldn't
that doesn't even have the ability to
prescribe you any sort of medication
they're gonna work usually in a specific
and focused type of therapy so they may
be trained in CBT for example or sorry
another what a cognitive behavioral
therapy CBT yeah so it's just a
prevalent type of their therapeutic
strategy relatively facted one as well
so they made yet they just may take you
through that therapeutic process so
there's very different ways that
different aspects of the mental health
field would look at different cases and
and treat them when it comes to
generalized anxiety which I think was
the overall question um like you would
treat it differently because if you have
a chronic form of a mental health
disorder or a psychiatric disorder like
you know depression or anxiety or you
know some other form of you know
neurodivergent a situation that you're
in that requires you know consistent
follow-up through time you're going to
need to continuously people have you
know your behaviors and your outcomes
monitors so that you can really like see
the patterns through your life and see
what you know what your triggers are and
how they affect you what what does calm
you so that you can like build a
paradigm - - for yourself to function
optimally for your situation if it's
situational that's not something that's
going to be your requirement you need to
figure out how to in the moment analyze
where your
anxiety is coming from and how best to
cope with that anxiety or depression
calm yourself down because you haven't
yet gotten to the point though it is
plausible that you could that you've had
enough I guess
trauma to your neuroanatomy by virtue of
you know your your the neuro chemicals
in your brains like your serotonin or
dopamine Aeroseal choline all you know
being produced either too much or too
little over time because of the
situation that you're in that can cause
changes so it's important to ask act
fast if you start getting situational
depression but for the most part people
will get through it it's just a matter
of what what type of trauma they've had
during the experience and how best to
manage their weight or the experience so
that it isn't predicated through the
rest of their lives and so that it
doesn't become something that you know
has a serious detrimental effect on
their decision-making processes on their
relationships
that even if they get through the other
side of it has ripple effects to the
rest of their lives does that make sense
yeah yeah okay so so you're saying the
situational anxiety and depression is a
big problem are there any other things
that you're seeing that are that are
consistent I think less physical
activity and poor nutrition is something
that yeah there's a lot there's a lot
less physical activity and poorer
nutrition and that that doesn't just
have physiological it doesn't just
affect you know what what clothes you
get to wear like have physiological
effects and mental effects especially if
you if you have something like some sort
of body dysmorphia for example or eating
disorder of any kind but this is a
situation where that could be
exacerbated work/life balance is going
to be something that's really difficult
for people because now they're rather
not working and unable to pursue
employment or they're working from home
and trying to balance their home life
with their work life simultaneously so I
think that's a little bit difficult you
know
early and people dealing with isolation
and the relationships in their lives is
something like reading about that was
actually really interesting yeah
because other people love their families
and they love their spouses and they
love their children they've never been
locked in a house with them for a month
person that you are they hire Lee
changes the dynamic of a relationship
and that not gonna have you know lasting
and acute effects on the relationship
itself and on your mental health so I
think those are the things that are
gonna be unilaterally prevalent right do
you have anything that you thought of
well yeah I mean it's just that this
really is new like I want one of the
wonderful things right now is we still
have solid internet access and so we
actually for people who are used to
interacting on the line a lot of the
social interactions are still pretty
solid online and you know a lot of
people you know my my my dad's wife
she's she'll call her sisters and stuff
and should she'll call them she was
doing this before she'd called like an
hour a day so the people with habits
like that had habits like that already
are probably doing better than people
that don't have internet access or or
just aren't used to you know that they
want to go out and hang out with
everybody I'm noticing a lot of my
friends in Ecuador who are just always
outside all the time and hanging out in
large crowds all the time it's really
stressful on them you know they're all
they literally they can't do it they
keep hearing that they're supposed to
stay inside but they're just screw it
I'm gonna have a party on the beach and
Wow
it's it's just it's just not working
well they're they're not able to contain
it because of this and I feel like kind
of the the more reclusive
culture and North America and Canada
because well especially in Canada you
notice here we have really cold winter
so we're used to sustainance indoors a
little bit like yeah I suppose that's
kind of prepped us for this but it
really is yeah it's it's new so so we
got all these problems and I want to
talk about how best to deal with them I
have the other big thing that you
pointed out is this these you know
eating disorders I think yeah like for
me I you know my diet is you know
Marilyn and I try and eat really healthy
and fresh vegetables and rice and beans
and it's usually it's stuff that's not
super addictive to eat because it's I
don't know it's just like fresh food is
it's good until you're full and then you
don't only want more but now we've got a
bunch of like canned food stuff that has
been engineered to make people eat more
right yeah which it's also wonderful
because it stays forever on the shelf so
but now we're like surrounded with that
I'm definitely eating more than I should
and I imagine we're gonna have a big
yeah a big problem with we could have a
problem with heart disease we can have a
problem with unwanted pregnancies
because people are getting bored and I
bet we're gonna a second baby boom after
this you know there's like yeah I but
what everyone was scrambling to go to
the grocery store I tweeted make sure to
get condoms everybody well people get
online and learn alternative methods for
family planning I suppose yeah but yeah
that could be bad we're gonna get get a
bunch of unwanted children out of this I
mean if people want children then that's
great but yeah surprise children bonus
children
we're getting some comments here people
are saying it's gonna be worse in the
hot summer months that's definitely true
it's a Bruce Hobson because yeah it's
gonna be too hot to stay indoors and
also there's too many beautiful things
to go do outside with groups of people
or they'll tow or people will justify it
by saying well I'm going to a remote X
location so I should be fine
but when thousands of people make that
decision simultaneously using the same
justifications and then they all show up
there what do you do turn around go home
great right yeah well the other thing
I've been worried about is like I
actually started this about two weeks
early because everybody was saying that
the virus wasn't here yet but I knew
that it was because I've been following
the data on the World Health
Organization and I knew from the data
and surrounding areas that it had to be
here already
like there was no there's no way it
wasn't so I was telling people you know
several weeks ahead of time to like you
know start being extra careful and I I
got my groceries like three weeks early
and everyone made fun of me I got my
stash I made sure their Twitter paper
was good I didn't go crazy with the
toilet paper you know I just got made
sure that we had enough and that was
because I you know I didn't I had been
doing this animation on on I've been
following the data for a long time but I
don't remember where I was saying that
where oh so so so I've actually been
doing this earlier so I'm actually a
little bit more sick of doing it then
other people might be because I've are I
already stopped like hanging out with
going out with friends and stuff before
it was a thing in my community and I'm
worried that we're gonna hit this moment
where everyone's just so sick of this
that they're gonna be like screw it I'm
going out and we're gonna have a party
anyway or when we when we first start to
see the numbers starts to dip a little
bit that's gonna happen and then we're
gonna see our numbers spike again so
it's gonna be yeah I'm I don't know if
how long we can maintain this
I'm not gonna be what's happening
because people are already in the midst
of it like in the thick of it right now
at the beginning of it when we're when
we know that we need to do these things
to make an impact people are already
giving themselves justification like I'm
just gonna go out quickly I'm gonna be
safe well my son can go see his
girlfriend because they've been in
quarantine too like you know like people
find these justifications constantly and
like I said like but when thousands of
people are all providing those same
individual justifications to themselves
for why they can bend the rules just a
little bit that it becomes a cumulative
issue and also this is something that I
didn't put put in there but this is
something that I think is really serious
to can especially from a psychological
aspect is that now we're locked inside
our homes let just consuming media
sources and then yeah vomiting our
opinion about them on to our social
media pages all day every day and people
are really really unaware of a lot of
the science surrounding it a lot of the
the information that goes into the
decision-making process to influence
people into how what lens they should
view this situation through and a lot of
that and and because we're bored because
we have nowhere else to do it because
that's the only way that we have to
connect with one another where we're
engaging in it we're participating in
that we're perpetuating it and we need
to be we need to really promote to
people that information discernment now
more than ever like when it comes to
source methodology is something that's
really really important you need to look
at good sources you need to know how to
analyze what isn't isn't a good source
and you need to help you know propagate
those sources to other people and you
know as gentle as possible because there
if there is a tsunami of misinformation
thought is building that's going to wash
over us and cause this to get worse
yeah and the other thing that I've
noticed is it well I mean it's
well-known that people are way more
aggressive online and they are in person
when they have an opinion
about something yeah and so that the
view that we're getting of our friends
and neighbors is super distorted right
now if we're not combating that I
actually feel like people have been more
calm on Twitter and so on
since this started I may be just like
the weird circles that I'm in but I feel
like people who actually call them
things down a little bit as opposed to
normal like Twitter's normally a
dumpster fire but yeah and it's Facebook
but I am seeing seeing a lot of people
like with very extreme opinions and even
like spending a lot of energy on stuff
that they can't control like people are
people are just so angry about the wet
markets in China and they're flipping
out about them but we we have no power
over what happens in China right oh yeah
especially we as individuals but we do
have power over what happens in meat
markets and so on here in the United
States and what what sorts of things
that we consume and I you know I keep
bringing up every time people are
attacking Chinese culture for the wet
markets I keep bringing up that the
swine flu that killed somewhere between
150 to 500,000 people back in 2009 that
started because of the pork industry in
North America like that's this like we
can't we can't demonize another culture
because they did something that caused a
disease when we don't demonize our own
culture for doing the same it's just a
just an ink consistency so I yeah
there's there's a lot of it but like I
find blame though right to find blame
right then what they need to find
somebody who's accountable that they can
point to because they think that's gonna
bring a resolution that will prevent
something like this in the future and
it's looking at it's not looking at the
people you can't blame a group of people
you can't blame a culture that a virus
develops naturally yeah I mean you just
that's ridiculous to me hey look at how
its spread and how we can put
preventative measures in place like
those would all be productive things to
do right creating polarized you know
cultural
sedation's of people just it seems like
counterproductive to me yeah yeah it
says I I you know in the in the past
that humans have a really difficult time
understanding that natural disasters are
natural like in the past we blame things
on demons on witches on gods now we
blame them now we blame LaVon
now we blame them on Donald Trump or the
World Health Organization or Chinese
culture it's like we can't we can't
admit the fact that like the human
species we exploded there's tons of us
and all of us have different interests
and some of our interests put us in
contact with diseases and then they
spread through our communities because
we're all interconnected through flights
and there's seven like seven and a half
billion of us whatever the number is
right now so it's very like this really
is I mean we can we can do things like
figure out which specific cultural
practices that we're doing are are more
dangerous than others and figure out
what the balance is there between you
know individual freedoms and community
safety and you know China seems to be
starting to take this seriously with the
wet market stuff the Chinese government
and what we don't know what's gonna end
up happening there but it's a you know
the the the meat industry in North
America tried to clean things up a
little bit in the pork industry after
the swine flu you know we're not
monitoring viruses and in the pork
industry now are trying to to see if
there's going to be anything can easily
jump out into humans but like I mean did
you know that eating your eggs runny is
actually a huge risk for bird flu no
scientists have been warning about
eating runny runny eggs for a long time
they've been saying yeah if you eat your
eggs runny
that's that puts us all at risk of it of
a swine flu of a bird flu
and we're worried that a bird flu if a
strong bird flu breaks into the human
population it could it could be like 40%
of the population that gets killed it
could be really bad so arguably eating
pangolins is safer than eating runny
eggs so it's just it's really hard to
you know the these the spillover events
are super rare events and they're I mean
it's just they're so freaking many
people on the planet and we're we're all
doing so many different things that this
I mean things happen so yeah it's I wish
we have like more of a solution oriented
approach to these problems than a blame
oriented approach approach to resolution
of these problems it seems humans are
very much more associated like focused
on who to blame than they are how to
prevent or solve a problem right right
yeah it's it's punishment rather than
correction is it's kind of the well I
don't know and I don't know how much
anger there has to be I mean I'm sure
there has to be an amount of social
anger and outrage in order for a change
to happen I think that's that's like a
part of the process but it's just like
while we're dealing with this change
it's just they from a personal level the
amount of hate that you want to feel
every day yeah you should probably tone
that down especially if you're sitting
around a lot of eating eating fatty
foods you don't want to also be enraged
all the time and have your blood
pressure extra high yeah so I'm making a
recipe for a heart attack
right I recommend people calm down and
enjoy this time which brings us to my
next question for you my next question
for you is like what are you seeing
about this this that is awesome like
we're now in our homes were with our
family well some people are not with
their family some people are actually
alone but we have we have more more time
to stop and think and breathe a lot of
us do what are you seeing the benefits
of this
I think that there's a lot that people
should maybe consider as beneficial
during during best like taking a moment
to just you know put your put your you
know busy hectic incredibly scheduled
life on pause and be able to have self
directed day planning to be able to
really think to yourself what do i
prioritize in the run of a day like
what's important to me what should I
focus on that's an opportunity that we
don't generally have in day-to-day life
yeah because we are so regimented just
like the way our society is constructed
you know we have to work and we have to
get to soccer practice and we have to
you know that we have to go to a meeting
and we need to be able to be at this
family event at this time we need to
find time to go to the store like all of
that stuff that we Jam into our days
that takes all that time away from us
that all of that's been stripped away so
now we have both introspective moments
where are we're made of introspective
moments and we can really focus on how
we want to constitute ourselves how we
want what we want to put into ourselves
how we want to schedule out a day why we
make the choices that we do like god
those are all opportunities that that
time being given to us it like that that
is a gift that we wouldn't have had
otherwise if you can take a moment to
remove yourself from the stress of why
you're in the situation that you're in
and focus on the fact that you know
where you are currently you're safe and
now you have time for you
what would you like to do for yourself
in these moments I think that that is a
blessing Dutch people maybe aren't
looking at as a blessing because they're
so focused on the things they can't do
they don't realize it oh I've been given
all of this time to figure out you know
who I am what I want what I'd like to do
with my time what I'd like to focus on
and if I'd like to research what I'd
like to learn something would I like to
take up yoga yeah you could do all of
those things are open to you now and you
know if you're willing to just you know
take a breath yeah I I want to see
people in the comments if you can tell
me
if you have started a new hobby pairing
during this during this lockdown and
Shannon I'm curious your answer on that
but but first I want to address some a
point made when I just mentioned that
you know what I seem to have said that
eating penguins isn't so bad people are
like oh yeah where did it go I'm trying
to look at comments here so I can't find
it now but someone was like well yeah
but eating penguins to extinction is
super messed up and I do agree we should
not eat penguins to extinction but the
yeah as far as disease as far as as as
disease goes there there are lots of
issues with those wet markets I mean it
really is it really is a perfect
environment for viruses to spill over
into new species but the and and and we
don't want penguins to go extinct
they're supposed to be protected they
are in a danger group of animals so yeah
that's all still very important but what
I get what I was just trying to say
there is that like we you know what's
the saying you're the the kettle calling
the pot black right yeah so it's to just
we don't have power as individuals most
of us don't have power or connections to
actually stop something that's happening
in China so for us to spend a bunch of
time being enraged about it really is uh
it doesn't really do a whole lot of good
was we have a bias toward their own
cultural practices that right a lot
makes it sort of resistant to
information that demonstrates that you
know we may be doing something that is
consistent was the thing that we're
criticizing or potentially has more
possibility ensure but we don't see it
as like we have a everybody and when I
say we I don't just mean you know the
Canadians we as a human race have a bias
towards a preference to war
and seeing our cultural behaviors as you
know virtuous and justifiable and others
is not that and we don't often analyze
why we just judge right right absolutely
I mean the people that are using
pangolins for medicine are absolutely
convinced that a Pangolin is medicine
and it's important medicine so they're
the or that are using it for food it's
it's it's that it's an important part of
their culture I had I had friends and
again in Ecuador I go there every year
that we're eating sea turtles for a long
time because it was part of their
culture and they didn't they couldn't
understand it took him a long time to
understand it to finally be convinced
that sea turtles are endangered because
no they're not they're everywhere
they're they come to my beach every year
and lay thousands of eggs like they're
not endangered come on they didn't
understand that it was just you know
that and a couple other beaches in the
world where this happens so I get just
takes it just takes a while to realize
if you're doing something dangerous it
takes a while to realize that and it's
it's offensive to have a foreigner tell
you what to do you know I mean it's just
imagine if imagine if China was trying
to tell us that we can't eat bacon like
it's not that's not gonna go over well
or that we can't hunt anymore hunt deer
and there actually are legitimate
reasons why you know there's there
certain there's there is a disease in
deer that scientists are worried that it
will jump over to humans as well the
neurological disease it's similar to
Alzheimer's and it's really dangerous
right yeah you know I knew we're not
gonna people aren't cool with you just
telling you you have to stop that
because it might cause a disease in the
future and that's that's that's what's
you know that's what's going on here
let's see
robert says i'm against keeping
thousands of chickens in a shed - is it
okay to be outraged by both well
feelings are always okay okay we got
some hobbies okay learning sixty ways to
make a gin and tonic
alcoholism will be one of the diseases
that starts let's see am I getting if
you if you do at stated clearly it's
easier for me to see your comments so if
you have one of your hobby is do an ad
stated clearly alright sorry at stated
casually actually and it will highlight
that for me so I can I can see it in the
comments because I'm I'm really bad at
reading comments while trying to have a
conversation here let's see so yeah like
let me know what your hobbies are but
Shannon have you started any new hobbies
have I started any new hobbies I started
doing yoga which is awesome and I did
I'm not sure if you would call this a
hobby and this is maybe something that
we'll talk a little bit more about later
but one of the things that I've done to
keep social connection on is I started
an online Facebook group for my
community that's like a game night so a
couple of nights a week because I have
access to all of this camera equipment
and stuff because of this weird youtube
hobby hobbyists life set up for it right
so I can I have soom so I can have like
meetings with people so people from
their homes
can get together and you know kind of
play a board game together and still see
each other and interact as a group right
so I started a Facebook group amongst
the people that I know in the community
um who are isolating right now as they
should be
so that's and I post a link up there
every couple of days with a new game and
anybody who's available joins and we all
play a game together so that's what I've
I guess now I'm a tabletop game player
who does so virtually so I suppose that
would count as a hobby but it's no it's
a way to keep people more
interconnected right and keep itself
connected to people simultaneously well
you know sort of providing you don't
want to people that maybe otherwise
wouldn't have had it so that's something
that I've been doing um I've been with
my youtube channel focusing a lot more
on creating and generating content so
and so that people have you know
something to go watch like they have
more options available to them to fill
the time that they have in the day so I
have been focusing on which was one of
my hobbies already like doing a lot of
reading and research you know because
I'm a nerd so that's the type of stuff
that I do and because I have a little
guy we've been you know playing more
games and working a lot on school
related items and and learning so he's
learning how to cook so those are all
things that that you know I've
incorporated into my personal and family
life well isolating but I think I've
been back home we've got some that Scott
Perry that's my dad
he's been cooking and delivering to
friend's porches we've got is that it is
that it for hobbies folks I I really
haven't started a new hobby I just been
doing more of
I bet well I've been gone on a lot of
different YouTube channels talking about
the virus and I've been reading a lot
about the virus so I guess that's my new
hobby
I read scientific literature on
coronavirus cuz I'm doing a lot of
conversations about it the one special
thing that I have done is the potatoes
in my cupboard started growing little
sprouts and instead of throwing them
away I planted them I guess that's my
hobby well well I haven't haven't
actually planted them in the ground yet
I'm I put them in the window and cut
them into anyway I'm doing the prep the
prep for because I'm actually slightly
worried I might freeze again but well
yeah well that's a legitimate concern
this time of year
there could there could be a snowstorm
next week you know it's 20 degrees
outside today that's the yeah that's a
legitimate concern right so it's a I
we'll see we'll see if my my potatoes
grow but yeah I really haven't I mean I
just for me not a whole lot has changed
because I worked from home before this
so yeah you didn't have a lot of
acclimatization to go through when it
came to different forms of you know
socialization and day planning because
you'd already acclimatized yourself to
working from the home and you know and
you and you'll have a virtual life
that's active and busy and a certain
degree fulfilling so you didn't have to
create that for yourself where a lot of
people are starting from scratch like
you are the infrastructure builds you
had the your the infrastructure built it
seamlessly sort of transition into into
this as as a viable alternative yeah
yeah you're David weirdly because I've
been doing YouTube for a while I have I
have friends like you that I never
actually met in real life but it still
is like a fulfilling actual relationship
whereas I think a lot of people's
relationship with strangers on the
internet is weird or like on sincere
yeah different type of conversation I
think and a different type of
relationship as opposed to you know just
fighting with people on the on the
network sharing a thing you you know a
hobby that you like to talk about yeah
different or your curated pictures of
your vacation you know so yeah people
have people have their fake online
presence and yeah I mean everybody does
but like I have I have a lot of sincere
online relationships too because of
people I've worked with from all over
the place on and different projects
widget which makes it nice because you
know I I hang out with him now but let's
see
I I would like to know so we've talked
about some of the the horrors of this
and some of the benefits of this what
can people do to stay sane what what
should we be doing to really make the
best of this time that the weird thing
is we don't know how long it's gonna be
like it's which which causes an extra
anxiety it's like it's a vacation sort
of but you don't know how long so and
and you might get sick so there's lots
of anxiety but yeah what do we do and
it's all situational too because not I
for example I I'm very very lucky I can
work from home so my income isn't
threatened but on the opposite end of
the spectrum
I'm immunocompromised so I am zero
contact which means that I can't just
nip up to the store like I can't provide
those justifications to myself that
other people have the freedom to do
because they they aren't as legitimately
concerned about you know there are life
being in the balance when they make
those decisions but so every
circumstance is going to be different
depending on what your situation is know
if you're by yourself at home or if
you're coupled at home or if you're
coupled with children or by yourself
with children you could be at home not
working worried about how to pay your
bills and get food you could be at home
working and not having that as a concern
you can be legitimately concerned about
your life being in the balance or maybe
not be grappling with it at all because
you think that you're in the demographic
that would just easily recover and walk
away from from contact so I think what
keep that which I'm just using that as a
preface to say that what I'm the advice
that I'm giving is incredibly general
and if you are in a crisis situation you
need to reach out to a mental health
professional and the reason I'm saying
that in the opening is because it's very
important for me to communicate to
people that if that's something that you
think is a requirement you can pursue
those online like there are
our alternatives to face-to-face
counseling and therapy that you that you
can pursue now it depends very much on
where you are I'm very lucky I'm in
Canada so we have a mental health
authority here that we can reach out to
and they're setting up virtual
appointments for people and it's a
certain amount of them are covered
through our Canadian medical system now
so so it's not I was going to be the
case for everybody so but what there are
alternative well on that point in the
United States if if you don't have good
health insurance and your anxiety comes
from not having money I mean yeah you're
literally like what right talking to a
counselor is not even an option right is
potentially still an option there are
virtual environments where you can
actually have chats you can set up chats
with counselors that are volunteers
there's lots of volunteer lines that
exist for mental health crises Oh like
they're over the phone I couldn't give
you a comprehensive list for the
entirety of North America but it's
something that you should research if
you have the ability well it's about
Google to try and find a free counseling
session you could you you could just
google mental health support line okay
but that'll usually bring it like if you
have your Google location turned on
it'll bring up ones that are available
to you or you can go to your like if
your local hospital has a mental health
division I guess for lack of a better
word to call it like it has a component
of it it deals with mental health a lot
of those websites will actually say you
know if you have an emergency call this
number and there will actually be
state-run emergency lines that you can
call if there's a mental health
emergency like there's suicide hotlines
there's hotlines for for anxiety for
different types of crisis ease so those
are options that are available and they
can help work with you if the systems
are set up correctly to find you by
alternatives going forward or maybe see
if there's some sort of support you can
get during this time now they're likely
gonna be overwhelmed right now
realistically so your which brings us to
the second point is that you're going to
have to learn some coping strategies
you're going to have to take some
introspective time to breathe and focus
on coping strategies that work for you
now that may take some research that may
take some doing you may have to like
really sit with yourself and ask
yourself some hard questions but it's
very much plausible to just take a
breath control your breathing
think about your breathing and focus on
your breathing and that has the effect
of actually giving you something
internal to focus on that you're
affecting which causes you to be a
little bit more clear and less panicked
and it also helps to control your heart
rate as well which can affect anxiety
behavior so do try to try to do that and
focus if you get if you can if you're
able it's something I would recommend
it's definitely not going to hurt you
but just take a moment and freeze focus
on your breathing and figure out how you
can how you can cope yourself through a
situation if you're in a panic situation
and don't have those resources available
to you if not everybody's going to have
an acute onset of like a serious mental
health event like that that's gonna be a
small portion of any population but I
like to start with them because they're
the ones who are gonna need the support
the most for the rest of us that are
annoyed and anxious and trying to figure
out how to like orchestrate our lives
and are in a state of uncertainty and
you know are worried about our parents
and are worried about what we're gonna
do with our you know with our kids and
how we're gonna teach them and how we're
gonna work from home and where money's
gonna come from and how we're gonna get
groceries all of us are in this all of
us are in this together
so some of my recommendations would be
if you are working from home segregate
your work area from your the rest of
your house as best you can
so that your work life does not start to
become a component of your home life
that that's a risk but I found myself
falling into that because my laptop was
here I could check my work emails all
the time even though my laptop was home
before this I was able to mentally
remove myself and just you know put it
in the corner and pick it up when I went
back to work in the morning unless there
was an emergency I needed to deal with
but since my laptop was open and now my
workspace II it's my home I was finding
myself and going to my workspace and not
considering the effect that that would
have on my home life and segregating
those spaces it was an important way to
do that like literally physically just
from just putting something up in front
of it or actually closing my laptop and
putting it where I used to put it before
this yeah physically putting it away was
all a difference between its it's just
starting to in yeah be in select my real
life but and that wasn't a healthy state
for me to be in so like you need to be
able to compartmentalize as much as you
can the different aspects of your life
even though even though they're all
occurring in the same space which makes
it sometimes mentally difficult exercise
get some exercise got some exercise you
can do some exercise at home the
lethargy has an effect on you so if you
are used to being physically active or
even if you weren't used to being
physically active being sedentary can
actually have negative mental health
impacts and moving around can have
incredibly positive mental health
impacts so find out that do yoga
maybe there's lots of YouTube videos you
can watch there's lots of free resources
that you can utilize to get your body
moving that will that you can
incorporate into your life is that so I
want to talk about that a little bit
like what are the different things
available to people cuz most people
don't have exercise equipment at their
house like I had a gym membership before
all this which I never went to anyways
but I had a gym membership who does
right
now that's closed I mean I would I would
do it and you know I used to in the
summertime I go running quite a bit but
so we actually do have we do have an
exercise bike and we've got like a yoga
pad which I use for doing like push-ups
on and stuff because it's all hardwood
well
it's fake hardwood floor in my apartment
so uh I've been doing that now like
regularly because I'm not getting out
and just being active so I mean I do go
on walks but what I've done is I get on
the bike and I watched an episode of
Star Trek next generation which is 45
minutes long and ride a bike so that
that's that's what I've been doing every
day I didn't do it yesterday but I've
been doing almost every day which is
which is which is fun but I find that I
get really I get super bored when I'm
doing aerobic exercise and Marylyn my
wife she's a nurse
and she's saying that if you do get this
disease it's like running a marathon
you're you can't you don't have enough
oxygen so your heart stops starts
pumping like crazy and you know people
are having heart rates of 115 or so for
hours on end so she's like the best way
to get prepped for this if you do think
you're gonna get it which I mean people
should be preparing to possibly get it
is aerobic exercise which is why I've
been focusing more on that lately than
other types of exercise but yeah so that
that's that's what I've been doing and
I'm curious to see what other people are
doing for their home training workouts
and stuff but yeah there's lots of
interesting YouTube videos they've been
going through as I've been trying to
find because I can do it like I said I'm
gonna start doing yoga from home and
there's a lot because I have a yoga mat
it's easy enough right right you can use
a towel even but did Paul know well it
depends out of here if you're put if
you're on a hardwood floor I wouldn't
suggest that cuz you will fall on your
face who are who are personal trainers
are actually starting to develop
um in-home workouts where you can use
things that are just around the house
and components of the workout so those
resources exist you just have to look
for them and figure out the type of
exercise that best suits you some people
are gonna want to you know maybe go on a
treadmill and listen to some music
some people might want to just take some
time and dude like you know some people
might want to do aerobic activities but
there's there's alternatives I really
feel like exercise is really really
important because it's I'm finding it
hurt I was a soccer player
well I still am a soccer player and a
baseball player of my seasons gonna be
delay in starting for both of those
things and I usually a nice to run 5ks
like charity five case all of those are
canceled so all of that physical
activity that I get heavily is now just
you know gone from my life so I need to
find something that's a that's a
replacement for it um let's see the if
you know an ex-convict hit them up and
ask them what they did in there and
their self exercise they probably got
all kinds of ideas actually a friend of
mine has an app that he uses that was
designed by an ex-convict and it's all
it's all like workouts to get you super
ripped if you have no weights whatsoever
you can do in solitary confinement
there's just no group of people out
there that know how to deal with
lockdown hit a bomb hit up your hit up
your friends I think reading routines
super important to like waking up every
morning especially if you're not working
if you or if you are like if your entire
day is free or you do self-directed work
where you don't have to you know sit
from X hour to X hour Autodesk and
you're you know you're doing
self-directed job or you're
self-employed or you took the time off
or you were able to take leave or you
know for whatever your circumstances are
like waking up every morning and knowing
what your
at least a couple of things that you
want to accomplish with your day like
whether it's cleaning or reorganizing a
house sometimes reorganizing a space
like a change is as good as a rest like
just reorganizing like a room or a
closet or any other space tat like just
to physically change your environment so
that you're not looking at the same four
walls um okay it can't have a positive
effect it'll also get you a little bit
of exercise too it's a way to
incorporate both of those components and
you know those projects that people have
been putting up a lot of my friends
right now aren't renovating their house
like everybody's painting our kitchens
and redoing their bedrooms and I'm like
you know good you know you have a
project to focus on good if paint fumes
you know who wouldn't want to sign up
for that but yeah it's regiment in your
day like not entirely like don't sit you
know but from 10:00 to 11:00 I'm going
to do this after 11:00 to 12:00 I'm
going to do this but at least that
you're so small goals to accomplish
during the day or find something that
you want to incorporate into a daily
routine be that exercise or reading or
you know time for correspondence would
be important right now find like a time
of your day where you're you're gonna
check on people yeah that's like check
on people people that you care about
people around you people that you know
in your community people you don't know
in your community check with other
people to see if they've checked on
people so that you can encourage
interconnectedness within your you know
your town your city your community of
whatever community it is that you're in
you know instead of set a precedent for
other people that hey like we gotta
check on each other we got to make sure
each other is okay we wanna know what a
[ __ ] ways to remain connected and and
positive and encouraging I think all of
those would be good coping strategies do
you do you think that there's anything
that I might have missed on there
you might know I just want to summarize
everything so you're saying that you
said the things you said is to divide
your living space into if you're now
working from home have your work thing
if possible either in a separate room or
something that you can put away when
you're done and you're actually done
with it so you get very specific hours
as you're doing it and as you're not
that's super important I mean I've been
working from home for
years and it's is it's very important to
be able to have a thing that you shut
down actually actually had to completely
I would use my laptop for like normal
like if I was need to use the internet
for something that I had my work
computer even though it is yeah just
having a separate separate things was
was was good for me when I was all in
one room so actually when I first
started stating clearly I was living in
a like group house with a bunch of other
college students and you know I just had
one room so never have my bed and then
there was my workstation and so yeah
having just yeah be almost separate that
was was actually really helpful so the
first was separate work from the rest of
your life mmm-hmm I'd say maybe also
like if you have kids or something have
scheduled time where it's like hey this
is all quiet time where we're gonna all
go be quiet and you're getting separate
rooms dad is such a good and important
thing or even with a couple right people
need time alone yeah please and you can
be alone right next to each other but
yeah so have separate spaces separate
times for doing different things the
other thing you said was make schedule
your day right mm-hmm
then what was your thing exercise yeah
and was there another one that I'm
missing Chuck on people yeah and there's
one that I'm missing that you that I
appreciate you bringing it up the people
in your home you need to develop strong
communication strategies with them
because you know you want to come with
the other side of this with your
relationship with your family attacks
without you know with maybe stronger
together than prior going into this so
really sitting down and talking like
working out
effective communication strategies with
your partner in your home would be super
important and if you have children
working together whether you're whether
whether your partner is or isn't in your
home the other parent is or isn't in
your home working out communication
strategies with children right now is
really really important I'm in a
situation where I'm by myself in the
home with my child and his father is in
a different home but he his father and I
don't always communicate the best about
everything but we we communicate very
very well about the messages to deliver
to him and what's important about him
and how to discuss the situations in his
feelings so get figuring out how to
communicate what you need to a partner
to it would be really important like
instead of saying listen I need 15
minutes by myself can you like can you
just leave me alone for 15 minutes like
can I have say okay you know work on to
lip your message delivery because
everybody's in a high-pressure situation
to say something like no I've you know
I'm feeling some anxiety it's important
to me that we spend time together
however at this moment you know I just
need it's like 15 to 20 minutes to just
go be by myself and learning to respect
each other in that way and understand
that that's a human need yeah and to and
to respect boundaries with each other
that maybe you didn't have to set before
so communication strategies with
partners in the home would be super
important right now yeah yeah I've had
in my situate my situation Marilyn's
working because she's a nurse so she's
she's working in high-stress situations
all day and then she comes home and I'm
like I would I've been just working
online you know hanging out in solitary
so I want to I want to go hang out you
know and like talk to her and stuff and
she wants to get on Facebook or just
chill so we deal with that um and Smith
says eat healthy lots of fruits and
vegetables that's yeah but that is also
now for some people who are so worried
about getting sick that they're not able
to go to the hospital a regular basis
that's might not be the easiest thing to
do but what we did is we
there's lots of things you can stock up
on right now so I think a lot of you
people are eating peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches and tuna fish and so on
but also like a lot of like beans canned
corn there's a lot of things that are
healthy and aren't going to like I mean
if you're eating canned tuna fish every
day there's there's problems with that
because you've got some diversity
mercury and stuff yeah there's lots of
good canned veggies out there and like
we we bought a bunch of whole-grain
pasta which isn't the best but it's
better for you think things like that
that'll it'll stay on the shelf for a
long time but are still pretty good for
you
what if anybody else has like in the
chat has like anything that they've like
a strategy that's work for them and that
they may be able to share that maybe we
didn't hit on that would be interesting
to hear like people who have found
resolutions to these these types of
mental health problems in situational
confinement problems yeah I can't go
wrong with beans and rice I thought that
is true when I was in I lived in Brazil
for several years and all of you eat
there as feijoada like beans and rice
but it's it's like the best beans and
rice you never get sick of it it's I
don't know how they make it it's it's
amazing but I I'm not too fan too much
of a fan of just like a can of beans on
rice that's not that good but there are
ways to pursued like there's still go to
a grocery store and get like things are
more limited yeah but I still have like
strawberries you know but what I've been
doing is I've been buying fresh
vegetables and usually
use vegetables chopped up and stuff
anyway so if you chopping them up and
freezing them in Ziploc bags my deep
research so that I can just take them
out and use like them my mushrooms are
already pre-cut and I could just grab
them and like throw them in to my stir
fry or whatever same with my green
peppers and my red peppers in my onion
that's already pre chopped in ziplock
bags in my freezer so that I have fresh
food ready I'm not sure I was good
frozen and then re cooked yeah they're
totally fine yeah I was something it
like well I bought in frozen mushrooms
before and they always taste horrible
but I guess maybe if you buy fresh
frozen but yeah I know I buy fresh
mushrooms and chop them up and freeze
them and they're fine I use them in lots
and lots and lots of stuff I use
mushrooms all the time like omelets this
bag I pre spinach do I have a case of
spinach frozen in my freezer because I
use it to like because I always wilted
anyway when I'm cooking coz I'll put it
like in omelets or I'll put it on like a
nan bread pizza so I bought I bought a
big bag of it's frozen
sweets fine yeah I've noticed that here
at least in Montreal there's no shortage
of fresh vegetables at the grocery store
there they've been stocking I'm just
fine they've not been able to keep wheat
I'm sorry flour and sugar rice baking
now right rice pasta flour sugar all
that stuff is just gone like I think
it's just like you know I don't want to
go to the store every three days which
is what I would do if I was gonna get
eat fresh veggies every day but that's a
good idea just to cut stuff up and
freeze it but we we did buy quite a bit
of frozen food and stuff so we're frozen
vegetables fruit it doesn't work as well
well with though cuz I like fresh fruit
unless I'm gonna use it like if I'm
getting to the end of like where my
fruits probably not gonna be good
anymore I'll chop it up and freeze it
and use it in fruit smoothies yeah so
that I can make it last a bit longer
learn a new musical instrument that's a
good boy learn a new musical instrument
yeah I'm sure there's like apps where
you can turn your computer keyboard into
a real keyboard or something
or Amazon still delivering stuff you
know if you if you are able do there's
lots of musical instruments you could
order and help deliver to your door
learn on YouTube yeah an online lesson
Lewis says I like the fact that the
whole world is united against this at
the moment that gives me hope for us a
common enemy that that is something
that's pretty neat I mean it's you know
I I'm I'm especially aware of this
because of the V because Maryland is a
nurse but just the amount of information
that the first nurses that got hit with
this we're able to gain and then share
like all the whole nurse community is
sharing tips like this is what worked it
so this is what didn't these are the
traps that this virus treating this
virus causes so we're getting a lot of
there's just a lot of information
sharing it's been really really nice to
see it's just you know cross culture
across countries it's pretty cool sad
that it took this for all of us to
recognize the humanity and each other
though yeah stop touching your face the
other day and it turns out all of my
favorite hobbies are got are going and
going going to parks and I'm not allowed
to go to gathering in groups of more
than five and touching my face well it
looks like we're not getting as many
questions here what that means we did a
wonderful job yeah I guess we answered
all of your questions so let me just end
by saying thank you Shannon this has
been great I've always I've wanted to
have you on here for a while
I've been on your channel several times
down no we all together a couple of
times too yeah so apologia
the Paula GA channel for those who don't
know is that he deals with a lot of
creationist stuff so I've been on there
a couple times and then what did we talk
about on your channel we talked about
Neil Neil Neil Tyson his and he had
those sexual activations and we were
we're yeah right as that came out we're
trying to not sure how well that aged
but and you and Paul just recently had a
conversation on the channel a boat oh my
gosh we're here to talk about it
like we talk about consciousness no no
we talked about agency and I was mostly
just sitting there drinking to you
watching you right which was great that
was a good conversation oh yeah you've
been on a couple of times and it's
always great I always enjoy having you
on and she has stuff works we'll take
some well a religious person who has an
extreme
a very extreme view of things and she'll
just talk through it to really try and
dig down as to what it is a lot of
youtubers or just people on online in
general will be overly outrageous when
they're on their own channel doing stuff
and Shannon can pull them out and and
and help them talk through it in a way
that's actually actually makes them look
more rational which is which is cool but
my magic yeah you help us you help help
people think through their things and
actually look good so I won one thing we
did have a comment on this earlier was
about churches still trying to meet and
why that's why that's legal and I know
that you've been dealing with that on
your channel and I'm curious is that
really a big problem or is this a couple
of people that are being extreme like
counterculture and trying to rebel
against this this like yeah because most
church leaders seem to have accepted
right away that we need to be serious
about this right yes a lot of them did a
lot of them did like in my community 100
people recognized that okay look like we
can't do this like they realized they
knew that they could count to five and
that five was too many and that more
than five people came to their church
and they're like we need to keep people
safe we're moving it online right but
predominantly that's what happened here
like it just hasn't been an issue yeah
however it is an issue other places know
if the question is how prevalent is it
the answer is I have no idea I don't
have a map that I can look at that tells
me the exact percentage of churches that
have decided or determined that they're
going to stay open I do know that there
are prevalent apologists who people look
up to and respect who are encouraging
churches to stay open using completely
irrational dangerous apologetics that
are going to put people's lives in
danger and that that's worth talking
about and addressing and that there are
people who are listening to them who
think that they're you know anointed in
the blood of Jesus so they're safe and
they are not and they are taking
unnecessary risks and they are
potentially threatening their own lives
and definitely threatening the lives of
other people that they come in contact
with because the rules don't to apply to
them like they do to everybody else and
it's infuriating to me to be perfectly
and abundantly honest with you yeah it's
negligent and I don't know how people
can look at it any other way I
understand that people need their
personal freedoms and that religions
have you know certain types of
exemptions when it comes to many things
in society that you know can be
justifiable and sometimes aren't
justifiable but in this instance it's
not justifiable you do not get an
exemption when you are threatening the
lives of other people
interaction yeah I think you know it if
you haven't if you dear listeners happen
to be religious and you know of someone
who's who's got that attitude you're in
the best position to talk to him about
it because yeah I mean I'm not a
religious person Shannon you're not
religious so for us to go try and tell
people what they should think is
we're total outsiders right but I I feel
like there have been a lot of really
responsible people who figured this out
early and ya know we really need to
socially distance and they've been
talking to other pastors and it in
general what I've seen is it's been a
good response even if it's 1% yeah
that's a huge demographic right it's a
huge demographic and there's ripple
effects like this goes out exponentially
because every point of contact is a
point of potential transmission
everything you touch that somebody else
is touched is this potential point of
transmission every person that you come
into physical contact with and then all
three person they've come into physical
contact with is a potential point of
transmission if you're congregating in
spaces where everybody's touching
everything breathing each other there
nobody's wearing masks and people are
giving each other hugs and you know
shaking each other's hands like I don't
know I went to church for a long time I
know that at one point during the
service you stand up and you turn to the
person to your left and you shake their
hand and you turn to the person to the
right you shake their hand and say hello
to them look that that's what happens in
church services maybe there I I don't
know I just don't see why it's essential
and why it gets an exemption in what it
is so dangerous
and I wish more people would stand up
for like what what is their logic to do
they just not believe it's dangerous
like the people that are running these
churches that are staying open do they
think to themselves that we really
literally are immune because God will
protect us or but I just don't I can't
wrap my head around the motivation yeah
I mean I feel like um I mean it was hard
for conservatives to to take this on
early as well and I think the reason for
that is there's that I mean part of
being conservative as being anti big
government and and you know not being
not whining the government to tell you
how to live your life and I think
yeah I think what we're seeing is
because it's mostly like in the south
and American South I'm seeing a lot of
these people they're saying no and
they're they're trying to meet in big
groups anyways in a weird
in a weird you know I think people who
follow me know that I'm not a very
Republican leading but in a weird way
I'm actually glad we we have Republicans
in power right now because when they
finally took it seriously like everybody
knew like oh this is like for real for
real oh because okay just just think if
if we'd had Democrats that won the
election they might have acted sooner to
to start the shutdown but there would
have been a lot more rebellion from from
conservative thinkers I think it's kind
of hard to predict and I don't know I
don't know which situation we were
better off in like the Trump
administration hesitated forever because
they're trying to trying to not mess
with the stock market so they hesitated
for a long time yeah they hesitated for
a while on on the lockdown stuff and so
that caused that that gave us an open
window for the diseases spread maybe if
a Democrat had been in there they would
have paid attention to the scientists
earlier but once you had Mike Pence on
stage saying you guys we need to listen
to the scientists and he's on stage with
scientists that's like everyone's like
holy cow
Mike Pence wants us to listen to
scientists this is serious all right
let's do this I think I think in some
ways this has been a blessing in
disguise right I don't know I just don't
get it like your threat like you're
threatening people do you or you just
have to not believe it I think you would
have to literally just not believe it
otherwise you're actually just
subjecting a portion of your
congregation to potential permanent
disability or death yeah yeah I think I
think those churches will stop as soon
as people start getting sick in there
and yeah yeah but I mean this is what
this is what we saw is like hey because
it really does seem if it weren't for
the fact that marilyn is a nurse and
she's saying that she's seen people at
the hospital that have had the disease
like I wouldn't have any first hand now
I still own that first hand I have
second hand knowledge of it yeah so it
is it is hard to believe until you see
it that something is is this bad that we
need to stay in our house like we had to
hide in her house it's a we'd never done
this before this is unprecedented
right so it's it makes sense that people
are struggling with this yeah look at
Newfoundland Newfoundland had no cases
and then somebody with the virus that
was asymptomatic went to a funeral and
that kicked it off like that's just how
it started in Newfoundland and gave it
to 20-some people at that funeral
that's how started an asymptomatic
person walked in and made a bunch of
people sick because people also don't
think about their head wrapped around
the fact that you don't get it and it
immediately falls sick yeah you get it
and could be asymptomatic the entire
time or could be asymptomatic for a
couple of weeks and then get deathly ill
like it manifests differently depending
on what your immune response is going to
be to it yeah and I'm not sick how do
you know especially in America you don't
know you're just anyway I get frustrated
it's like I can't go anywhere I
literally might die and I understand
that right when I see people make these
justifications to themselves well you
can't take away my liberty that's like
saying okay look you might my life
doesn't matter to you people like me
yeah don't matter to you you're not
willing to take safety precautions cuz
no one's gonna tell you what to do
you're not gonna take away my liberties
now is going to take away your liberties
we're trying to protect each other and
you've decided that you're exempt from
giving a [ __ ] sorry I swore I don't I
don't know this is and this is a classic
problem with trying to debate what
freedom is right is because you want
your people to be as free as possible
without stepping on their neighbors
freedom and so there there gets this
it really is tricky especially tricky in
the case like this you know should we
ban eating of wet egg yolks no I got one
one more question here any thoughts on
the Yolo party in Mexico and I just so
for those who don't know I don't know if
Mexico still doing this last I heard
Mexico was just not changing anything
they're just business as usual and
they're just gonna let it I guess let
the virus just spill through yeah and I
I don't think that they'll be able to
maintain that politically very long
because people want when people start
dying people want a powerful leader to
be showing that he he or she is as
caring about this right yeah you know
they want someone to step in and and
prove that they actually care about
these deaths so I don't know that
they'll be able to maintain that very
long if they can it will be horrible but
scientifically interesting because we're
gonna see what actually happens if you
do nothing because because pretty much
every other country is trying to do
something so if they actually maintain
it which I don't think they'll be able
to but if they do it'll be interesting
to see because my suspicion is that the
virus will just naturally shut down a
community anyways the death rate will
will skyrocket the hospitals will get
jammed up first of all death death rates
will will be way higher in a country
that does nothing and then people will
just actually get so scared that they'll
stay in and I don't know if they'll
recover faster or if their economy will
be hit less hard from that so it's going
to be a economy versus corpses type
thing or if it's going to be or if
they'll get hit harder worse on both
sides I don't I don't know I've been
curious to see England was saying they
were gonna they were going to do that
too early on they were just going to
quarantine people who are extra
susceptible and that lasted like a week
and they immediately back
and it did a lockdown like like we're
having in Canada right now too so if you
do live in Mexico I recommend that you
for your own safety follow a lockdown
similar to what's happening in the rest
of the world for your own safety it's
very unfortunate that your cotton ax in
a community that's not wanting to do
that with you but I yeah we'll see what
happens there industry well on that note
yeah thanks for coming Shannon it was it
was great having you on and next week my
twin brother is going to come on asking
me some questions
hey he was asking me a bunch of
questions about evolution and the immune
system and I was like we should talk
about this on Sunday morning science so
my twin brother will be on and we'll
just be talking about evolution the
evolution of microbes and the evolution
of organisms I guess with these complex
immune systems and how it is that even
though we evolved so slow we stay ahead
of these little enemies that can evolve
super rapidly so that'll be that'll be a
fun conversation cool until then stay
curious everyone and yeah I'll see you
next week